hello so first I'd like to thank Fong
hung in the other and the McGovern
Institute for inviting me here it's a
real honor to be here and I'll be I'm
excited to share with you some of our
recent developments on optical sensors
and control elements so so as as Jeff
Lichtman has elegantly just talked about
technology has really always driven our
understanding of the brain in fact it's
the field of neuroscience is at any
given time defined by the types of
experiments we can do because the brain
is such a large and complex organism so
disruptive technology is what you can
consider disruptive technologies have
really driven what we can do in
neuroscience and of course that started
out with the Golgi stain as we just
talked about being used by romona qahal
and then later on of course because it
brings electrical or oregon the ability
to actually record what electrical
signals gave us great insight into what
the brain was actually doing and then
later on the ability to patch-clamp the
membrane and measure the contributions
of particular channels to the action
potential gave us a more mechanistic
understanding of how that electrical
signals was being generated and most
recently in the past 20 years or so
optical methods have become have
revolutionized our ability to
investigate the brain and many of those
optical probes are based on fluorescent
proteins and as we know fluorescent
proteins are very versatile because they
are a genetically encoded light source
and all you really need to get that
light source is to take your gene which
encodes your fluorescent protein and
express it in your cell type of interest
for example in the very first
demonstration of that
Harilal gets expression GFP in the worm
nervous system or fuse it to a protein
and you can do more complicated things
like you can make
a sensors of particular signals in the
nervous system based on fluorescent
protein so as many of us here use the
calcium sensor gcamp
is a green fluorescent protein on which
has been attached a calcium binding
domain Kumada lean in such a way that
when in the absence of calcium the green
fluorescent protein is dim but in the
present calcium it it assumes it's worn
normal fold and becomes fluorescent and
the details of that have been
investigated by labs such as Lauren's
who unfortunately can't be here today
and of course that's very useful because
we can now visualize in real time action
potentials in circuits in living brains
so that's on the optical sensing side of
course even more recently has been the
revolution in optical control led by
Edie and foam and Carl and with this
nice picture from our hosts the idea is
apparent you as we know you can generate
action potentials or you can hyper hyper
polarized neurons using light and of
course that gives us and then with with
subtype specificity imposed by the
genetics so that gives us now control of
the nervous system firing so where are
we going next in terms of technology
development well I think a lot of us
have a common goal of putting as much in
the nervous system under optical control
as possible and that's because of the
great complexity of nervous system and
so having optical control which is which
can be temporally and spatially precise
is a major advantage experimental aim
and of course there's always a need for
more better sensors and so I would say
on the sensing side
our lab has identified some some holes
in our toolbox that we would like to
fill
besides gcamp which is a sensor of
activity but uses calcium as a proxy for
an electrical activity we would like to
make sensors that are very robust and
have millisecond
to really look at the defined timing of
neuronal electrical impulses and in we'd
also on this timescale of events where
electrical activity is fast and protein
activity is of moderate speed on the
order of minutes and permanent changes
are more more stable changes in nervous
systems such as structural changes to
the synapse are on longer timescales of
hours we have some general methods such
as fret reporters to look at protein
activities but we don't really have
well-established methods to look at long
term structural changes and on the
control side of the equation we have the
rhodopsins to perform up update genetics
at the on electrical activity at the
millisecond the second time scale but we
don't have great methods for controlling
protein activity or controlling long
term changes in the nervous system so
we're talking about three probes that
we've been working on in our lab the
first one for looking at structural
synaptic plasticity the second one for
looking at millisecond timescale
electrical activity and the third one
for optical control of protein functions
and potentially synaptic structure as
well so we'll start with the structural
synaptic plasticity reporter as as many
of you here are experts in much more
expert than me
we know that synaptic growth underlies
many learned Network properties so for
example in the campus everyone's
favorite system place cells are emerge
during exploration of a new space and
that emergence is thought to be due to
snapback strengthening at particular
synapses which is somewhat like LTP as
we study in in a slice in hippocampus
slice and in the hippocampus of course
the primary excitatory neurons are the
pyramidal cells for example to see a one
primitive cell and on the pyramidal cell
dendrites are thousands of synapses and
those synapses can - to a large degree
be modulated in terms of their strength
in your size individual
and we know that modulation that's
required for long term potentiation for
many kinds of long-term potentiation
requires new protein synthesis and many
and much of that new protein synthesis
probably happens locally because
dendrites are are filled with mRNAs and
ribosomes and you can see them in close
proximity to to the synapses even with
thin spines in this e/m by kristin
harris and course this was known for a
long time since experiments by kendall
in which protein synthesis inhibitors
were applied to slice as LTP was
performed in the in control slices LTP
stays up over two hours but in the
presence of inhibitors of protein
synthesis LTP decays after about an hour
and so together these kinds of these
kinds of data have suggested a model
whereby activation strong activation of
a synapse through release of
neurotransmitters induces the
translation of RNAs that are
pre-existing in the dendrite into
proteins and those proteins are then are
then taken up by the by the activated
synapse and those proteins might include
structural components that would help to
make the synapse grow and stabilize
synaptic growth and so this is a pretty
commonly accepted hypothesis but the
problem we saw was that it was really
hard to actually find strong evidence
for this hypothesis and the hypothesis
will predict that there are new proteins
that are delivered specifically to
growing synapses another way to frame
this would be through alternative
language of this hypothesis that
synaptic tags when you li put newly
synthesized proteins that specifically
label stimulates synapses exist I mean
if those tags exist can we use new
protein distributions to mark stable
potentiated synapses serve as a reporter
of stately potentiated stenosis so to do
this we wanted a way to specifically
label only newly synthesized proteins
and not the total protein pool and to do
though to do that in the live neuron and
so we devised a reporter that's based on
a fluorescent protein but basically is a
drug induced well fluorescent protein
with a drug giving you control
all over whether or not you have
fluorescence so we want drug to gate
protein fluorescence but to gate it in a
in a time-dependent manner so the the
probe we came up with is this which is a
little bit complicated to understand but
it's pretty easy to use so what we do is
we infuse a protein of interest for
example like PSD 95 the major synaptic
structural protein 2 - a tag an attack
consists of half of GFP then a protease
which is surrounded by cognate protease
sites and then the other half of the
fluorescent protein the protease is by
default will cleave itself out and we
use hepatitis C virus protease with its
non-toxic expressed it in in mammalian
neurons without causing any effects and
it has a very high sequence specificity
for its substrate so it doesn't cleave
it doesn't cleave well in transient is
include many other substrates so it will
cleave itself out it would actually then
get degraded but this will this will
this will break the GFP before has a
chance to mature and so that you never
get fluorescence but the other reason we
chose this this protease is that it has
very good cell permeable inhibitors that
have developed to treat hepatitis C
virus so we can take one of those
inhibitors apply it to your neurons and
then from that point on newly
synthesized proteins don't suffer the
degradation of of the GFP so the two
halves of the GFP are held close enough
together with any because the paralysis
is blocked and then that GFP has a
chance to mature and become fluorescent
so basically it's very easy to use in
the absence adding a drug everything
that was made is not fluorescent but
after you had a drug everything that's
made from that time on is fluorescent so
here's a movie showing it working time
zero is before we add the drug and over
the next 21 hours we're just looking at
PSD 95 fused to this tag which you call
timestamp yfp and we can see where new
newly synthesized PSA 95 goes so PSN 85
was always there in the culture in the
neurons it's just
before we add the draw we can't see it
so after the other drug you've seen you
kissing 95 localized to 2 throughout the
dendritic tree but it seems to go
earlier it is some synapses and not to
others and it's precisely that kind of
heterogeneity that we're interested in
capturing um so what we wanted next to
do was to specifically stimulate some
synapses on the neuron but not others
and then ask whether new PS t95 go
specifically to to the stimulated
synapses and I should say that we
hypothesized at PSC 95 would be one of
these proteins that are newly translated
in response to synaptic stimulation
because it was identified as a potential
target for FM RP an RNA binding protein
that's mutated in fragile X mental
retardation and is localized to and the
RNA has been has been shown to be
localized to dendrites so so we wanted
to ask for the PSNI 5 would be
synthesized and go specifically to
stimulate his synapses so we cultured
neurons and these culture chambers that
are made out of PDMS they're basically
very simple microfluidic devices and the
chambers have two compartments which are
separated by a wall the walls 50 microns
wide and through the wall run these
little tunnels that are 7 microns wide
and so that's wide enough for neurons to
send their dendrites and axons through
but too narrow for the cell bodies to
migrate through so you can see in your
on stuck here trying to get through you
can only get its dendrite through and
that allows us to apply a stimulus to
one side and hit some neurons on that
extended end right through and thereby
preferentially stimulate these synapses
on this neuron not synapses elsewhere of
course we could try a local perfusion as
well but we found this to be a more
reliable way to do this so in this
experiment we've added BDNF as a as a
model for synaptic growth and synaptic
stimulation so BDNF is is sufficient for
a synaptic change that looks like LTP
and in some groups believe that it's
also necessary for endogenous LTP so
BDNF is applied on this side and it's
going to diffuse down these tunnels
where
encounters synapses on dendrites of a
neuron that's actually lying on the
other side of the barrier so you can see
and we now look at new PST 95 after we
add the drug to both sides so we can see
PSN 85 wherever it comes up and this is
the time course here so we could see
what looks like new PST 95 enriched at
stimulated regions at the at the point
of closest encounter to the BDNF that's
coming down the tunnels so indeed it
does look like PSC 95 goes
preferentially to stimulated synapses so
we then explored other stimuli that
might be a little bit more physiological
if we stimulate M glue ours with M glue
our agonist the HPG so M glue ours also
gate LTP at high doses as people you're
very familiar with it causes Ltd but at
low doses it facilitates LTP so it can
go either way
so the HPG applied to the right chamber
will diffuse down to the tunnels and in
this in this location encounters
synapses of dendrite from this from this
neuron and you can see here at the early
time point newly synthesized PFC 95 in
individual synapses of that neuron we
can also this is another agonist of M
metabotropic glutamate receptors again
we see preferential localization new PSE
95 - the stimulated us - stimulated
portions of the dendrite ins very
obvious here compared to an EM cherry
cell fill and we've finally done this
recently so that those they were
published in our Nature Neuroscience
paper we've done this recently with with
glycine LTP which which we thought was
important to show since in the previous
cases we're using formica logical agents
in this case we're using glycine to
induce LTP that's that's triggered by a
release of endogenous synaptic vesicles
and this is NMDA receptor depend LTP so
we see on the site it has glycine on a
site it has no glycine so on this side
the NMDA receptors being facilitated we
can see what looks like early and
abundant new PST 95 on this side so is
this new is this due to local
translation is that due to pissing i-5
that's made in a cell body and then is
brought to the synapse we can't really
rule out the latter possibility we favor
the former possibility and the reason we
favor it is if we remove the 3-prime utr
as we've done in this experiment we
don't see local early local PSD 95
accumulation at the stimulators site
instead you see what looks like a
gradient a movement of PS 95 from the
cell body so I hope that sir parents a
little fast but it wasn't so fast before
upgrading my computer but anyway so you
can see what looks like a wave of new PS
1085 coming from the cell body so in the
absence of 3-prime utr the PSE 95 RNA is
not localized in the dendrite remains in
cell body and so we think this is in
direct evidence that the effect actually
does require local translation of PSE 95
the other evidence that I might require
local translation of kissing 95 would be
if we fail to see this in an FM are PE
deficient Mouse for example and so we've
been doing those experiments and
actually very recent data it's very
premium any data we actually do see a
defect in new PSC 95 localization to the
stimulation side in PSE 95 deficient
mouse neurons so so many for this part
is that using this reporter of nearly
synthesized proteins of specific
proteins that you're interested in we
have what we believe is direct evidence
of a newly translated synaptic tag and
its effect requires a 3 prime
untranslated region which is the region
that contains elementary localization
and repression and the effect is reduced
in FM RP knockouts and so so we believe
that the hypothesis of local translation
mediated by activity in FM r FM RP is
does hold true for the case of PSD 95 so
ongoing efforts will be looking at
really establishing the the severity of
the defect in FM RP knockouts finding
other proteins that also may be targets
and then using our system to go into
mice and then visualize the distribution
of new proteins
in dendritic trees in in for example ca1
neurons during learning to do that we we
had to make a knockin Mouse and so we've
started doing that for both PSE 95 and
another another gene arc and we're
further along with arc because we we
started it
knowing that arc would be a positive
control so arc as many of you are aware
is a protein whose is a gene whose RNA
is synthesized it's transcribed in
response to activity but it's it's RNA
is also translated into protein and
responses activity and so we you we
tagged it with timestamp to serve as a
positive control for our later
experiments with est 95 so to do the
tagging is pretty standard we've put in
this timestamp boy if pica set a
c-terminus of Arc we also have this frt
flank PG Canio's positive selection
could set the a at the ESL stage it
looks like that and then after we made
mice that go germline we performed the
flip recombination to take out the PG
Kenya cassette so we've actually just
got those mice on there homozygous
viable which is nice but previously we
had a homozygous viable frt neo frt
cassette containing mice and we started
just verifying that those neurons
actually do have drug dependent arc
signal so those are some chimeric mice
they're yeah they're cute as my should
be and then we take out that we took out
the neurons from the mice and plated
them in culture and this is these are
you don't see anything here because the
neurons were not treated with drugs so
we don't see any signal as we as we'd
want if we treat with B D and F alone
most of the time you don't see signal
but oh yeah you know you don't see
signal because there's no drug if you
used to you with a BM s protease
inhibitor alone most of the time you
don't see signal but you see signal and
a couple of neurons one is here we seem
to have some ongoing arc synthesis and
then up regulates as arc synthesis at a
particular time there's also a neuron
here that you can see more weakly where
there's some low level of art comes up
but this is just what the inhibitor low
no stimulation
and then if we add the inhibitor plus
BDNF to stimulate arc synthesis there
you can see very robust our new our
expression in many neurons and culture
so it does seem to work and so we will
be using those mice in the near future
so that's the first part about
structural synaptic plasticity so I'll
move on to the second part which is
electrical activity so as we were
talking about fluorescent proteins allow
real time optical sensing of neuronal
activity with calcium reporters and
that's been used for a long long time
interestingly the first calcium reporter
was it's a long time ago thing was it's
um I think it was in 1997 and the first
in and since then calcium reporters have
gone to many iterations development they
have been worked on by it probably at
least five labs continuously for over a
decade and so we're talking about more
than 50 maybe a hundred people years of
work going into developing better and
more sensitive calcium sensors and
that's let us now the G chem six this
was G chem three that I was showing here
but we now at G chem six which gives you
these really large signals in response
to single action potential so you can
visualize single action potentials with
calcium sensing however calcium as as
many of you are aware is not everything
in a nervous system it's it's a it's a
proxy of neuronal electrical activity
and it's a it's a slow and not always
direct proxy the voltage signal itself
is much richer than the calcium signal
it's faster because the action potential
is up and down within two milliseconds
whereas the calcium signal persists in
the cell for hundreds of milliseconds
you can have subsidized oil changes that
don't lead to calcium an entry into the
neuron those could be either
hyperpolarizing or depolarizing so if
you want to look at up-and-down States
for example that's completely silent in
terms of the calcium response but
there's definitely a voltage change so
people have been interested in voltage
sensors and when we started our work the
the best
that sensor was probably arc light and
arc light has a large fluorescence
response about 40% from - 70 + 30
millivolts and so it has a largest
voltage the largest we'll just dependent
fluorescence change of any sensor and so
so people are quite interested in it and
arc light is a fusion of pH sensitive
GFP Florin to the c-terminus of this
four helix bundle which is the voltage
sensing domain from voltage sensing
phosphatase so a voltage sensing
channels and voltage sensing
phosphatases use this for helix bundle
which on which the on the fourth helix
reside positive charges which since the
transmembrane voltage so in the polar I
say that inner on the interior is more
negative than the positive and this
helix is down in the depolarize state
that helix moves upwards for reasons
that are still not understood the the
flooring when fused to the c-terminus of
this voltage sensing domain becomes dim
in the peephole or a state when it's
moved upwards
the problem with arc light has been its
kinetics the original arc light had up
had on kinetics about 15 milliseconds
and off connects about 30 milliseconds
which is an order of magnitude slower
than action potential itself and so it
wasn't very sensitive for action
potentials that's been improved very
recently by by the pair of own lab so
they've they've changed the voltage
sensing domain from C squared C onna to
the chicken and that is a faster voltage
sensing domain and so the connector has
been sped up to I don't quite remember
but something in the high single digits
of milliseconds but it's still a little
bit it's still slow as you can see from
the timescale here that these the widths
of these these fluorescence transients
are about 20 milliseconds still much
wider than action potential itself so we
wanted to make a new design for a
membrane voltage sensor that could
possibly be faster and so we we started
looking at what was known about the
structure the voltage sensing domain and
that time we started the there was no
snow structure of one domain in the up
and in down States but there was a
molecular dynamic simulation
based on a potassium channel what is
sensing domain in both the up and down
states so actually I'm running this this
a movie from this paper which I run
backwards because they were actually
investigating the closing of the channel
the original structure was in the
Upstate so I ran it backwards so now the
movie is starting with the channel and
at downstate and now it's moving up and
so something you see does very
interesting so we'll see it again who
starts down moves up it doesn't look
like much of a change but what's
happening is the s4 helix the read helix
is moving upwards as everyone expects
but not only that but something is very
something very interesting is happening
in the s3 to s4 loop extracellular loop
of this protein the this loop this loose
linker is actually forming an extra an
extra helical turn after it moves
upwards so I think you can see that now
this loose and now it moves upwards and
this extra turn forms right so it's kind
of like putting a telephone cable back
and so we thought that maybe this
location be a good place to insert of
conformational a sensitive GFP and this
kind of change is very recently just
this year and seen again in the ciona
voltage sensing domain in this structure
by eduardo terrazzo and and in this
structure it's a little hard to tell but
the the black the black one is the
resting down state in a white form is
the Upstate and they were able to get up
in up-and-down structures for one
protein of the ciona phosphatase VSD and
in the Upstate you can see what looks
like an extra new helix so it's a little
bit different from this this new helix
is not attached the s3 but but there is
an extra coil and so we thought that
would be a good place to try to try to
link conformational changes in the
voting voltage sensing domain to come
from conformational changes in GFP so we
took this circularly permuted GFP same
one that's used in G chem we tried
several ones and the end we use a GFP
that wasn't from G chem but it's the
same circular
mutation that everyone uses to make
conformational sensitive GFP reporters
and we inserted that in the s3s for loop
and we screened just a few constructs
and many of them showed voltage
sensitivity and we just used the one
that showed the largest change and have
the fastest kinetics and what we see
with these sensors is that actually
again they're bright at baseline but
they're actually dimmer upon
depolarization that's consistent with
more strain being put on the GFP barrel
with the expert coiling of the alpha
helix only extracellular loop so we call
this because it's very fast it has on
and off Millis kinetics of two
milliseconds each we call this
accelerated sensor of action potentials
or ASAP so ASAP has a dynamic range in
the total dynamic range that's very
large over over 50 millivolts from the
from the physiological resting state of
minus 70 to deploy positive 30 as about
a 15 percent change in fluorescence and
as kinetics are 2 milliseconds up and
down as I as I alluded to which is order
magnitude faster than the original arc
light and so when you when you apply a
voltage when you apply an action
potential waveform the fluorescence
rates of ASAP one follows the shape of
the of the voltage traits quite quite
well whereas arc light is blunted due to
its time averaging effects and you can
see what you can see mock Meany epsps
and ipsps
well tracked with ASAP one not so well
attract with arc light the same is true
with a three AP burst and because it's
fast kinetics you could take you can
take action potential trains up to 200
Hertz and we believe up to 300 Hertz
although we haven't tried with with ASAP
one you could see in single trials
without averaging you can follow every
single spike whereas with our Clyde you
get this flat baseline due to time
averaging after 100 Hertz in neurons you
can tell in electrical trace where you
have means and ApS you can see every
mean you can see every
P with high signal noise whereas with
Arclight you can't be sure if the a
piece have happened or not so basically
it it's it we think it's pretty good it
gives you the large variety of
electrical events in neurons that you'd
like you'd like to be able to
differentiate means you'd like to see
meanings you'd like to be able to see
your ApS you'd like to know how many PS
had it happened so a SEP will give you I
think most of those things under the
right illumination conditions the one
thing that you would want to be mindful
of of course though is that because a
SAP is so fast you have to image a high
repetition rate so with gcamp because
the signal persists for about half a
second you could image it at 30 Hertz
and and capture a piece when they happen
but in voltage because the signal is
gone in the few milliseconds you really
should be acquiring at 500 Hertz or a
thousand Hertz and so that means you you
just need to get a fast CMOS camera
they're not too expensive these days
like the flash for just 16,000 and you
need to use enough they did well yeah
well it used to be much more expensive
that I'm not being paid by home a lot so
either and-and-and-and you need to apply
enough light to your sample that you can
see signal over noise within your 1 or 2
millisecond exposure but it's it's it's
doable we're within the doable range for
example in this case we've taken a
neuron in culture and we put enough
light on it imaging at a thousand Hertz
that we can see action potentials with a
signal-to-noise ratio of a4 or so and
you could see leaving the light on for
15 minutes this is this axis on the
order of seconds and this is at the
beginning of experiment 15 minutes later
which is 900 seconds later they're still
going the neurons still putting out
action potentials if we could still read
them with some other signal the noise so
you can you can image for maybe half an
hour or maybe more with the right
imaging conditions so unfortunately we
don't have pretty neuron movies we have
near our movies but not pretty because
we do them in for high sensitivity and
binning but we do have nice HEC cell
images so this is a HEC cell that's been
and then taking through voltage steps
and you could see with thousand Hertz
imaging the the fluorescence responding
to voltage alright so anyway we're
that's it for the voltage sensor but
we're of course trying to make it a make
it even better we have some ideas about
how we could make the dynamic response
even larger so last I will tell you
about optical control of protein
functions so visualizing time and
location of protein activity has
provided a lot of insight into the
mechanisms of synaptic plasticity for
example on the left is a movie from Roja
Yasuda's lab looking at a chem kinase
sensor looking and in this movie they're
able to show that cam kinase is
activated in the individual spines in
response to neurotransmitter stimulation
but that activation is very transient
but of course chem kinase 2 activity was
required for LTP development if you put
on a kinase inhibitor you fail to get
LTP so this shows that chem kinase the
requirement for chem kinase is very
early and transient and he and his lab
has gone on to you to do fret reporting
for many other signal transduction
molecules and worked out their their
logic in the circuit of synaptic
plasticity I'm our lab was also looking
at using fret sensors to look at relay
activity during axon guidance and it's
developing neuron I'll just show that
events happen locally and quickly in the
growth cone but besides visualizing
protein activities can we control the
time and location of protein activity
that would be really nice with imited
test hypotheses about what's really
required and where and when it's
required but of course there's no easy
generalizable way to control protein
activities quickly or locally
transcriptional regulations to slow
chemical agonists are often not specific
and if they are that's if they're
available they're often not available
and the neither these methods allowed
spatial control so what we want ideally
is to have a method for making
that our photo regulatable and the
method should be generalizable and
they'll be graded for a hundred percent
genetically encoded like GFP without
requiring chemical cofactors and it'd be
most convenient if it if you could just
make one protein that would be optically
controlled without having to Co Express
something else and of course we don't
want it to use UV light we want to use
non-toxic wavelengths of light so when
we first started this we considered all
the natural photo regulated systems from
plants and bacteria and of course many
other labs have been pursuing this as
well and so other labs have taken
systems like bacteria phytochromes UV ra
for the trope in rhodopsins and linked
them up link their natural light
responsive functions up to mammalian
protein functions but in none of those
systems are the four criteria fully
satisfied the four criteria
generalizability cofactor independence
single chain construction and non photo
toxicity and in terms of the
generalizability what we were most
interested in in was creating a system
that looked like this conceptually so if
we could fuse to the to terminate of a
protein of interest domains x and y
which bind to themselves at baseline
then that might be sufficient to
inactivate the protein especially if the
NNC term and i are flanking the active
site or the binding site of protein but
then when we put on light if light
dissociates x and y then that would open
up the protein so the only promise what
should x and y be we thought about
adapting some of these natural proteins
to become x and y like reversing their
they're thought they're induce ability
by light but in the end we we decided
engineer completely new protein protein
light regulate interaction and that was
by none other than our old friend
fluorescent proteins and that's yeah
because we know not only do we love
fluorescent proteins but they actually
have they already meet the non cofactor
requirement no cofactor requirement and
we actually have you have structural
features that are very similar to the
natural photo regulatory proteins from
plants and bacteria namely they undergo
a lie
dependent conformational change so we
use a fluorescent protein named rambha
some of you may use it for its photo
switching properties it's green
fluorescent at baseline but it's
switched off by the silent light that's
used to illuminate it and then is
switched on again by violet lights so
sign light is 500 by light is 400
nanometers and other labs have shown
that this photo switching corresponds
with assist trans isomerization of the
two two rings of the chromophore so
originally the chromophore is in the
brights estate when it's illuminated by
500 in their light it flips to the other
side and it becomes dark and then it can
be flipped back again by 400 nanometer
light but on this side NMR studies has
shown that there's a loss of structure
along this this barrel surface of the
protein and we simply notice that that
barrel surface is the primary dimerizes
in dimeric and tetrameric forms of
fluorescent proteins so we asked if you
were to make a tetrameric format drama
which you can make by single point
mutation residue 145 to asparagine which
you have a following situation where the
bright form of the drama is a tetra mer
but when you shine cyan light in it on
it it monomer Rises and then when you
shine violet light on it it goes back to
touch mer this was really easy to show
actually as a drama tetramer is
tetrameric drama 145 and it's tetrameric
before light treatment after cyan light
illumination it runs as a monomer on
this native gel and after violet light
the same sample will now run as a tetra
mer again so it's fully reversible and
it's quite robust and we can then now do
this protein sandwich that we wanted to
make we put drum pad 145 in at both ends
of a protein of interest we chose
intersecting because it's N and
c-terminal flanked its active site and
so the expectation is that at baseline
Trempealeau form a touch more and then
this will create a large steric
hindrance to the active site and
occluded but when you shine cyan light
on it then the tetraman would dissociate
and then intersect and we'll be able to
interact with its substrate which is
cdc42 so intersecting is AG if it's a
guanine nucleotide exchange
factor which activates GDP for gtp
exchange on cdc42 thereby activating it
three c42
as many of you know mediates of
formation of Filip podía which is
involved in chemotaxis and
synaptogenesis so to show that this
would work we put this intersecting
fusion which we call it flip for a
fluorescent light and useful protein to
the membrane where you can that where it
can be in position to activate cdc42 and
then we shine light on on cells
expressing this construct and what's
nice about this system is the drama
fluorescence gives you an idea how much
light you need to shine it gives you a
direct feedback on the activity state of
the protein so in this case we put on
enough light to bleached romba of
fluorescence to about 33% of previously
which about thirty seconds so you see
the drama fluorescence going down and
then after that happens we look at we
look at an Emma Neptune fastened in
fusion so this is a far r.fp fusion to
fasten a Phillip Odia marker to look at
a formation of Phillip Odia so prior to
elimination there very few and only
short Phillip Odia and after after
illumination there are many long Phillip
ODS so it does appear to work and here's
a movie I'm out of time so here's a
movie which is not playing for showing
the induction of Phillip Padilla after
light stimulation so light stimulation
was at zero and after that you see the
formation along Phillip Odia it's
generalizable as we wanted to be so we
generalized it to a protease if the
protease is activated it will cleave
away a cherry substrate from the
membrane so you see the cherry starting
at the membrane and after a photo
activation you see cherry filling up the
cytoplasm so we think that we can apply
this potentially to induce structural
plasticity in an especially specific
manner so because Phillip Odia are
believed to be a predecessors of
synapses we took a developing neuron of
14 days in vitro and illuminated it part
of its dendritic tree and you can see
the you can see the the formation of
Phillip Odia after illumination of
course there's a lot of little pretty
formation going on at baseline and so to
do this well we had to do it in the blah
so we had to get a couple it took I
think two high school students and one
spouse postdocs spouse in the end to do
the quantitation but in the end we were
we see what looks like a fifty percent
increase in the in the above the basal
rate in philippi formation within the
illuminated region compared to the non
illuminate region of course we don't
tell the people when there's going for
formation what was done so you know they
don't know what was illuminated what was
not illuminated
they just score all the new Philip Odia
and so so we see this increase in Philip
Odia formation and it seems to translate
to increase in spy information as well
and so we believe that eventually
translate to increase in synapse
formation so the advantages of our
fluorescent lighting digital proteins
over other methods we believe is that
it's potentially more generalizable to
your particular protein of interest and
it's single chains cofactor independent
and uses cyan light actually which is
not used by any other natural systems
and it's self reporting because it's a
fluorescent protein and also because
it's based on a fluorescent protein we
think it's potentially extended
extensible to other wavelengths because
there are red switchable fluorescent
proteins as well and so we like to apply
to some more different proteins more
colors as mentioned optimize our
performance and then seek new
applications and so in terms of photo
regulatory proteins in biology to take
the big picture in terms of photo
regulation there are many natural
proteins that involved in sensing light
and changing biology but I think we can
add to that this first example of a
unnatural protein we don't think this
happens in natural fluorescent proteins
we think it's an engineer feature of
fluorescent proteins has been engineered
in the lab so I think this is the first
engineered protein light dependent
protein interaction so just to sort of
give you a little motivation you can
learn a lot by by looking at by looking
at things happen like watching TV and so
we've had TV for you know 67 years now
but you can learn even more by doing it
at a computer you can actually move
things around
really as much more powerful than
looking so if you were you can watch
somebody play the piano and you know
that there's this thing called a piano
and they can make music and I like you
know there's a brain and it can you can
you can do something but if you really
want to learn how to how that works then
you'll be nice to actually try to play a
piano and so I think with protein photo
control we could start trying to learn
to play the piano of the brain so so of
course you started the easy songs so in
summary what I've been showing you and
talking about is our efforts to fill in
this matrix of of optical control and
optical sensing I mean what's
interesting is how much of the matrix to
me what's interesting is how much of the
matrix is filled by a fluorescent
protein so this one class of protein is
really quite versatile even more
versatile than we imagined just a few
years ago so that brings me to
acknowledgments these people helped
these people perform the time stamp work
Francoise perform and yang performed the
ASAP work in collaboration in March
knitters lab and and and CIN did most of
the flip work thank you for your
attention
um going back to your time stamp I just
it just occurred to me what's special
about that dick wait about 13 how does
it have to be because I remember yeah
inhibit her actually it's a protease
inhibitor right it's right hard to
penetrate
yeah how does it compare to say that
this stabilize domain developed by Tom
one dose right so I think there are two
components to the question when is
protein degradation and the other one is
drug permeability so this protein
degrades due to the placement of an
enroll it do things amino acid at the
cleavage site so there's a role by which
the first amino acid at the n-terminus
the determines protein stability if it's
a positive charge it's very unstable so
we put a positive charge why to have to
cleave its site so this gets degraded
away but when you in this conformation
that cleavage site is not exposed so
then the animal is not invoked the the
drug is very cell permeable and and the
nice thing is it gets the drug class
gets better and better so every year
there are better versions of these drugs
that are less toxic and now there are
three approved drugs for humans so you
could just go and senator Cruz has
started selling them so you can just go
buy them now it's very convenient
it doesn't penetrate the blood-brain
barrier the drug is 600 Dalton's usually
above 200 Dalton's you don't get good
penetration actually Roger's lab has
been working on a new method to get
these hydrophobic drugs across the
blood-brain barrier which apparently
shows three decent results and so there
there actually may be a way to do it
it's aided by complex ation with
nanoparticles which I guess get enough
of them get into the this the
endothelial cells I've formed the
blood-brain barrier to get on to the
other side to release the drug on the
other side but for now the best way to
use it and the way we're planning on
using it is
cannulation so in the in the in the
hippocampus where we were interested
looking at CA one distributions in new
arc we need to cannulate anyway to put
an endoscopic microscope there so we
could just go down the same bore with
drug can you replace it was the
destabilize domain oh yeah so we didn't
want to do that because if you were to
destabilize the okay so one idea is why
don't you just put destabilize GFP on
there and it's going to it's going to
turn over very fast and so in the basal
state you don't have very much signal
and then when you induce new protein
synthesis you have more signal and this
is true like people have used
destabilize GFP on its own there and
Sherman's lab is used it on its own to
show that new protein synthesis occurs
and is and is is a stimulus induced but
we don't we didn't want to tag something
with it we're interested in seeing where
the proteins go and we didn't want to
tag p95 with that because then you would
be constantly degrading PSD 95 and that
might have effects on synapses also
that's not at all or nothing' thing it's
not binary so you can see fold
differences right but what we want is
something as a sharp as possible so we
could get the best signal over
background induction but it's a good
question
so for the flip system you showed nicely
that you can and use it very well
I was wondering so you showed those
native Charles and it seemed like the
violet light cannot bring everything
back to tettemer so how well can you
switch the system off yeah it's a good
question in vitro it's very efficient on
this this one that I showed you is I
would say representative but sometimes
we get even more complete restoration so
in this in this Joe
you see some monomer at baseline anyway
in the you see some monomer at baseline
anyway before elimination and so this
brings back everything to within
experimental variability so I think it's
complete the and that that goes with
that corresponds with the previous
observation that drama is a very robust
for the switcher so people use it for
tracking purposes they can they can get
complete switching as well of the
fluorescence so we just see this
correlates nicely with the fluorescence
and then other experiments where we use
less protein we don't see this at all
now this is a hundred micro molar
protein since we're talk about
concentrations there's a hundred micro
molar protein so that shows that the KD
of this interaction is greater than a
hundred
however the KD of this interaction has
been measured at less than 10 so we're
getting more than more than tenfold
difference in affinity on the switch
right you're actually right yeah so the
question was for the kinetics of
activation and activation so the
kinetics I mean we know the kinetics are
for the bleaching here for those
switching here and they're not super
fast and we've actually made me into
drama that do switch faster so I mean
the kinetics I think are within the
usable range so within 10 seconds you
can get your you're more than 50 percent
your protein activated but it's true
then the protein that needs to go find
its partners and do its thing and that
just will depend on the particular
protein and so with with the cdc42 with
Phillip oh deformation we seem to get a
delay of like 15 15 minutes before we we
see some failure right away but we don't
see really huge effects until 15 minutes
later and we think that's just a matter
of the protein finding its substrates
now you can imagine that with the with
the holding these two domains on either
end the protein is not going to find its
substrates as easily as a normal protein
but I think that unfortunately is an
experimental limitation that you have to
model into your into your interpretation
thank you